So what will people ask me and
my happy with all my past investments?
I say that is the same question
like saying would you as manager
high school life the same that as
you managed them when you were a kid
knowing all you know now and
the answer of course no.
I would have been great in high
school today, would had a great time.
And similarly when you start investing
there's many things that you miss out.
At least for me there were many
things I missed out on and
then I only learned over the years.
I think that if there's one thing that
is the most critical thing is that
earlier on I think my balance between
team and idea was very different.
I think that if you
gave me a great idea,
or something that looked like
a great idea with a mediocre team,
I might have gone for it and
I actually have in the past.
Because my view was,
which was a wrong view,
that at the end of day the ideas
is very material in that.
The reality being at the end of the day
that as I said most companies that come
even with the best of ideas find out
very quickly that they don't have
product market fit which
is a very depressing thing.
You start out, you start running you
go to the customers you do customer
discovery bang suddenly you find out
that nobody wants what you thought is
the best idea in the world.
At that point your ability to go back
to the drawing board come up with a new
assumption try again and
again and again and
again depends mostly on your character.
And so
if you believe like I do that nobody is
born with the ability to predict exactly
what's going to be the idea that works.
And even if you're born with that you
don't know what Google is going to
do tomorrow, what Facebook's
going to do tomorrow, right?
And then, you know,
you can work on something for years and
then Google comes and says,
I do that for free now.
And so it's the ability of
the founders to look at the market,
understand it, look at the customers,
understand their needs.
Come up with ideas that serve these
needs and enter it very fast to success
which is the main thing that will
determine their success ratio.
And so the initial idea,
the only thing it does is that it tells
me whether they're really smart or
not because really smart people don't
come with really stupid ideas usually.
But other than that,
I don't put a lot of focus on this and
I used to do that in the past.
So when I look at some of the companies
that invested in early on
I probably would not have
invested because I had
thought that some of the teams
were okayish, not perfect.
But the ideas were good and these
company, it's clearly did not succeed.